[Music]
first of all I'm thrilled to meet you I
love the movie and you're so incredible
in the film and then to realize this is
where you're starting I mean you you
this is this was your first big break
yeah this is my first big break yeah and
it's good for you I I watch your lot on
TV oh you've seen I had no idea few D if
you would know me you've seen me before
on TV a lot a lot yeah yeah I don't
understand how you move the hair that's
what you've taken away from no other
question just how had the hair yeah yeah
yeah it's what would your questions got
as far away the movement the movement
oh you can't incredible I'm not talking
to you about that it's done with wires
and yeah let's let's make this about you
and then more about me in the film you
play a Somali pirate you are from
Somalia originally that's right but you
moved to the United States when you were
much younger how old were you when you
moved to the US fourteen fourteen and
you and you grew up in where'd you live
Minneapolis when you have to live yeah
Wow okay so what's interesting is they
had a casting call is there a large
Somalian population is the largest in
North America yeah so that's where they
decided when they were making captain
Phillips they said let's have the
casting in Minneapolis to go and find
some pirates yes and when you need
Somali pirates you go to Minneapolis
how many people showed up for the
auditions it was about 700 or 700 yeah
okay and you get the role which is
absolutely amazing and the other Pirates
who were chosen there's four of you all
together yep they were your friends oh
yeah you knew them already yeah
we lived on the same building fin we
knew each other very well that's
incredible I know is you're all amazing
and you get to be in this movie with all
of your friends now your co-star Tom
Hanks the biggest star in the world
right right you obviously knew who he
was who was your what's your favorite
Tom Hanks movie fourth gun you like
Forrest Gump yeah when you met Tom Hanks
as you get did you bring that up I told
him because we didn't get to meet Tom
until the first time we feel on the
movie but with the first day with your
shooting yep like with him that was the
first time oh yeah after the scene I
told him like I can't believe I'm making
a scene with the fourth gun guy
the forrest gump guy he's here tomorrow
I'm gonna have to tell him that how was
he with that he was ok with that
yeah he left ok good now were you
interested in acting at all before this
experience yeah I loved acting yeah you
know but I just happen to find a
shortcut yeah it's gonna say you're like
let's see I think ok I'm interested in
acting I think a co-star with Tom Hanks
in one of the best films of the year
what were you doing before what kind of
jobs did you have I was a chauffeur you
were shut you were a limo driver yeah
yeah it was how long were you a limo
driver for full body air yeah how did
you like it it was good you get to meet
new people yeah yeah and and and I would
think what's interesting now is you're
going to all these parties yeah I know
there's a limo driver driving you yeah
are you nice to the limo driver
absolutely no good all right you say
like look I know it's right there man I
know what's going on